jeder kennt allen masc nach dem verkauf
des unternehmens paypal investierte er
beinahe seinen gesamten erlös in das
private raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
sessions bereits 2030 den ersten
menschen auf den mars schicken möchte er
ist ce des autobauers tesla und war in
dem unternehmen ohb involviert welches
sich mit künstlicher intelligenz
auseinandersetzt mit seiner firma
neweling möchte man es bereits 2020
einen computer chip herstellen welcher
ist menschen ermöglicht einen computer
mit seinen gedanken zu steuern
außerdem hat ein auto ins weltall
geschossen marktfähige flammenwerfer
verkauft und eine glasscheibe
eingeschlagen
obwohl es natürlich auch an seinem
grandiosen team weg fahren sich darauf
macht der mann dass und wie kann nun
selbst zu so einem übermensch werden
aber das wird relativ schnell klar wenn
man seine biografie ließ und dabei
festgestellt dass er seine vision und
pläne über seine gesundheit einschlaf
und soziale kontakte stellt eine woche
werde ich mich der herausforderung
stellen und leben die der mann der für
die 1 als der verrückteste und für die
anderen als der größte mann unserer zeit
gilt dabei werde ich mir das verrückte
ziel setzen in dieser woche drei videos
von dieser art zu produzieren und
herausfinden wie sich elenas alltag auf
einen normalsterblichen out wir mit
diesem zitat lässt sich sein tagesablauf
ziemlich gut beschreiben er steht 7 uhr
auf verzichtet auf frühstück arbeitet
den ganzen tag und die zwischen 0 und 1
uhr schlafen nur um den nächsten tag
genauso zu wiederholen
vielen ist bekannt dafür dass er seine
tage in fünf minuten blöcke unterteilt
und jeden dieser blöcke mit arbeit voll
stoff genau das werden wir auch machen
damit kommen wir auch schon zum
wichtigsten teil dieser woche der
planung
es ist der sonntagabend einen tag bevor
die elon musk woche startet und ich
strukturiere gerade mein leben für die
nächsten tage auf die sekunde genau und
packe jede minute voll mit produktiver
arbeit wer leben will wählen maas hat
keine zeit für freizeit freunde oder
familie
ich werde um sieben aufstehen und um 0
uhr ins bett gehen abgezogen von 30
minuten duschen insgesamt einer stunde
essen und einer stunde anderer
unterbrechungen sind das 14 stunden und
30 minuten am tag oder 100 und 1,5
stunden pro woche
sofern man kein wochenende
mein auf leistung optimierter morgen und
sieht jetzt so aus
ich stehe um 7 uhr auf und steigt sofort
ohne nachzudenken aus dem bett ich
schnappe mir meine klamotten die ich
bereits am tag zuvor zurecht gelegt habe
und springe ohne zeit zu verlieren in
die dusche da ich ohnehin kalte dusche
habe ich großes interesse daran
schnellstmöglich wieder herauszukommen
und bin bereits nach drei minuten fertig
anschließend fülle ich meine haare
trocken ist eile meine frisur und putze
dann meine zähne ein kleiner
zwischenstopp auf der toilette 7 uhr 34
diese zusammen schreibtisch ich habe
etwas wochenende wieder einige fall mehr
aufträge bekommen die ich mich jetzt
kümmern werde in einem der drei videos
die ich diese woche produzieren werde
arbeite ich nämlich auf der freelancer
plattform und versuche dort in einem
monats möglichst viel geld zu verdienen
aktuell 25
jetzt wird das nächste video geplant in
drei tagen ist die vorpremiere von star
wars oder 9 und spaß und dazu möchte ich
an die du darüber machen wie ich ein
paar meiner visual effects clips von vor
zehn jahren mit meinem heutigen können
nach stelle 9 uhr 10 nehme ich die
anmoderation auf 59 die zu bearbeitenden
szenen und 10 20 setzte ich mich schon
an den pc um die effekte zu erstellen
jeder handgriff geht in den nächsten
über der übertrieben der wochenplan ist
essenziell für unser ziel von drei
videos in dieser woche da er mir dabei
hilft mich zu fokussieren ich lasse mich
von nichts ablenken
nicht alle zehn minuten auf mein handy
wie sonst immer und bin gut in der zeit
durch die knappen deadlines die ich für
jede aufgabe habe werde ich schneller
fertig als sonst fühle mich jedes mal
wenn ich eine aufgabe rechtzeitig
erledigt habe ein bisschen mehr
motiviert als davor und gehe dann mit
unserem hund gassi gehen hat
wahrscheinlich keinen hund weil er keine
zeit gassi zu gehen aber guckt euch mal
ab wie süße kleine ist
jetzt wieder zurück an die arbeit ja
noch viel vor uns
wir kommen langsam zum ersten mal etwas
in verzug der eine visual effects dauert
leider doch etwas länger als angenommen
und der nächste sprengt unseren zeitplan
sogar noch mehr ähnlich wie bei der
motivation von der ich vorhin geredet
habe die man bekommt wenn man eine
aufgabe nach der anderen erledigt
funktioniert es auch beim nicht
erledigen nur mit dem motivation
je weiter ich vor dem zeitplan ab trifft
desto größer wird der druck die zeit
wieder gutzumachen
es ist gerade die woche vor weihnachten
und der grund warum ich diese woche
gleich drei videos mache ist dass sie
zur weihnachtszeit zeit schon meine
familie und freunde haben möchte je
weiter ich also im zeitplan nach hinten
rutschen desto mehr muss ich über
weihnachten arbeiten
ich habe jetzt ein lichterfest hat nicht
vielleicht geschafft und noch nicht mal
mit dem rohschnitt dass daraus videos
angefangen ich finde jetzt gerade
element und weil es sich dank david
mainz über nacht und aussehen geplanten
30 minuten die wende das haus eingeplant
haben da wird natürlich auch nichts
draus und ich glaube dass wir sind die
beste medizin
da ich noch etwas besprechen musste bin
ich dann auch erst um 1 uhr 30 ins bett
gegangen
verschlafen stehe ich am zweiten tag
also auf und schleppte mich zum computer
ich renne jetzt im zweiten teil der 3d
szenen von gestern und das gelände der
stunde ungefähr dauern
deswegen lege ich mich jetzt noch mal
hin weil mein pc währenddessen e zone
prozent ausgelastet ist und wie ihnen
maske schon so schön sagt sie das
rebreak
der zweite tag fängt leider nicht zu
stromlinienförmig an wie der erste ich
brauche noch bis mittag nur um diesen
einen shot fertig zu stellen und bin den
ganzen nachmittag damit beschäftigt e
mails zu schreiben an leute die fragen
bezüglich meines schnitt kurses haben
und auch an marken mit denen ich in
zukunft gerne zusammenarbeiten würde
natürlich ist es eigentlich gut dass die
anfrage aktuell so hoch ist dass ich
mehrere stunden e mails schreiben muss
aber der zeitplan kann natürlich keine
gnade
da ich keine zeit habe mir essen zu
machen geschweige denn danach
aufzurollen
wie stelle ich über das internet etwas
zu essen die bestellung ist ungefähr 30
minuten an
gekommen ich schaue beim essen immer
gerne zum beispiel ein kurz gesagt video
da ich zwar beim arbeiten manchmal
youtube videos im hintergrund hören kann
aber beim essen habe ich eben auch meine
augen frei um sie auf die wunderschönen
kurz gesagt videos zu richten
obwohl ich gerne den ganzen tag arbeite
liebe ich meine kurzen essens pausen in
denen ich ein wenig entspannen kann ich
gehe wieder zurück ans werk aber erst am
abend beginne ich mit dem rohschnitt des
videos für morgen mittag einen tag
später als geplant um einige stunden
gutzumachen arbeite ich bis in die nacht
und stehe aus dem gleichen grund auch
eine halbe stunde früher auf und folge
streng meiner morgen routine eine
stabile morgen routine ist deshalb so
wichtig weil sie das fundament für den
rest unseres tages bildet wenn ich
persönlich schon morgens zu spät aus dem
bett komme denke ich mir häufig
unterbewusst wozu jetzt noch
diszipliniert sein der zug ist vorbei
ich mache die letzten aufnahmen für das
video welches in einigen stunden online
kommen soll und gehe an den final
schnitt fehlermeldung
ist jetzt schon eine stunde nach dem
geplanten zeitpunkt wir brauchen
mindestens noch eine stunde und der
fehler der nicht passieren würde
als das video dann um 16.30 endlich hoch
geladen war der alptraum eines jeden
youtube das video hat einen copyright
claim entscheiden was darf man star wars
musik nicht einfach so in seinen videos
verwenden
ich ersetze die musik renderer das video
erneut raus lade es noch mal hoch und
bahn
das video ist online in meinem plan
steht dass ich nach dem upload direkt
weiter arbeiter ich hätte eigentlich
schon vorher wissen sollen dass daraus
nichts wie es gleich mir nach jedem
upload alle kommentare durchlese und
diese auch meistens beantwortet
das video läuft von anfang an extrem gut
aber plötzlich die arbeit hat sich
gelohnt das video hat bereits nach 24
stunden um 600.000 aufrufe der rest des
tages vergeht schnell ich arbeite noch
ein zwei aufträge für das fallbeil video
ab und erwische mich dabei wie ich
nebenbei immer wieder auf mein handy
schauen um nachdem vorher hochgeladenen
video und den kommentaren zu sehen das
video bekommt zu spitzenzeiten 2000 auf
wofür pro minute nochmal alles für
meinen kanal 2 bis 4 100 um 0 uhr völlig
erschöpft ins bett und bin aufgeregt
aufgeregt wie rasant sich youtube gerade
entwickelt da ich dadurch länger als
gewohnt brauche um einzuschlafen hatten
wir heute nur fünf stunden schlaf
ich habe am anfang gesagt produziere in
dieser woche drei videos und ihr fragt
euch jetzt vielleicht wo denn das wetter
bleibt das dritte video ist dieses hier
ich produziere das video eine woche
leben wie ihren mast so wie elena es tun
wird denn ich drehe und schneider ja
immer diese experimente auch in der
woche in der ich die selbst experimente
durchführen und heute finden wir einige
politiker chance die ihr wahrscheinlich
nicht schon über das video verteilt
gesehen habt
[Musik]
gestern war der fünfte tag unseres
experiments normal arbeite ich sieben
tage die woche wobei ich dann am samstag
meist um 17 uhr mit entspannten abend
über eine freundin macht und dann am
sonntagmorgen wieder entspannt loslegen
mit der planung der nächsten woche aber
jetzt ist samstag und jetzt geht es
gleich für mich nach bayern über
weihnachten und zu meinen eltern
deswegen habe ich hier überhaupt zu
viele videos produziert in dieser woche
wir haben im schnitt mehr als die 14 05
stunden gearbeitet und sind auf 15,5
stunden pro tag gekommen
gerade weil ich vorgestern und gestern
deutlich länger gearbeitet hat als
geplant alles in allem fand ich es
richtig gut sein tag in fünf minuten
blöcke zu unterteilen und wirklich jeden
davon auch strukturiert auszufüllen
mitarbeit oder mit irgendwelchen anderen
dingen man kann er auch seine freizeit
zu allen plan aber es ist extrem
vorteilhaft einfach zu wissen ob die was
mache ich übermorgen was mache ich dann
und dann um einfach den fokus aufs
wesentliche zu verlieren und nicht am
handy abzudriften und dann eine halbe
stunde auf der toilette auf reddit
abzuhängen so wie mir das tatsächlich
manchmal passiert abgesehen davon war
der lifestyle den ich in dieser woche
jetzt gelebt habe gar nicht so viel
anders als meine normale alltag bis auf
das ich eben eine stunde mehr schlaf
aber ansonsten war das jetzt für mich
nicht ungeboren so viel zu arbeiten
wobei man natürlich sagen muss dass der
gute ideen maske deutlich mehr stress um
deutlich mehr verantwortung hat als ich
jetzt mit meinen videos die mir
natürlich aber trotzdem mir persönlich
extrem wichtig so wenn ihr das handwerk
des schneidens erlernen möchte kann ich
euch meinen schnittkurs empfehlen in dem
er innerhalb von zwei stunden
videomaterial alles jahr und weise für
youtube videos musik videos und sonstige
sachen braucht der link dazu ist in dem
video beschreibung ich mache beinahe
jede woche eines dieser videos wenn ihr
mich auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
dann abonniert gerne diesen kanal und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder was gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]